now stephen miller former trump senior
advisor founder of america first legal
stephen uh again we want to help the
afghan afghans who helped us in a
meaningful way a verifiable way and
there are many of those
but should we trust the biden
administration to carefully vet these
folks
not only should we not trust the bottom
administration to do so
the simple reality is that we no longer
are
in control of the central apparatus in
afghanistan to be able to vet anybody
the taliban has all of the control of
the government now so the notion that
people could just show up at a
checkpoint and demand resettlement into
the united states so we could have any
idea about their background their belief
system where they come from now that the
u.s bat government has fallen it's just
an impossibility but there's a more
important fundamental point that has to
be made
those who are advocating mass afghan
resettlement in this country are doing
so for political not humanitarian
reasons
it is extraordinarily expensive to
resettle a refugee in the united states
they get free health care they get free
education they get free housing they get
free food they get cash welfare
for the price that you could resettle
refugees in america you can resettle 10
times more
15 times more
in their home region in this case
primarily in pakistan
resettling in america is not about
solving a humanitarian crisis it's about
accomplishing an ideological objective
to change america and if we really want
to help people in the region we'll be
working with our partners to find a safe
place for people to go but that's not
america well i want everyone to
understand how fluid these numbers are
and again you hit the nail on the head
steven it is extremely costly i've been
getting emails from people about saying
well catholic charities is putting them
in this hotel in maryland and then
lutheran social services is putting them
in this hotel in virginia
and i'm thinking well it's not like
they're they're getting government money
to resettle the refugees right it's and
it's not just a one-time deal it's a
it's it's a decade plus of money they
get which again somebody has to pay for
it it's not coming out of you know
nicole wallace's wallet it's all of
americans wallets yeah and then and then
the local communities pick up the tab
for the education as well which is very
costly but just to just to get to first
principles here
the united states of america never ever
made a promise written or unwritten to
the people of afghanistan that if after
20 years
they were unable to secure their own
country that we would take them to ours
that is nonsense that has never been us
government policy
is no they keep saying it's but it's
been said all over cable we made a
promise if we don't live up to our
problem it's very heart-wrenching it's
hard as a as as a mom it is
heart-wrenching to see any suffering
it's happening in afghanistan we're
seeing suffering on the streets of
chicago we're seeing suffering in africa
syria everywhere libya and in somalia if
the united states takes the policy that
every person suffering under sharia law
has a right to live in the united states
of america we're going to need to make
the room for about half a billion people
is it just not intellectually serious
and as i mentioned earlier it's not
about humanitarian relief because it is
far cheaper to resettle afghan refugees
in pakistan and other neighboring
countries well the uae is helping with
these airlifts i understand from my
source tonight they're doing big amounts
of help to bring people out of
afghanistan the uae can take some of
these
folks as well they should they should be
more culturally at home in the middle
east and i think it makes a lot of sense
don't repeat the mistakes of europe
yeah well and europe doesn't want them
europe doesn't want everything
everyone's like we gotta listen to
europe they've learned they don't want
them that i'm sorry france says no
britain doesn't want them germany and
sweden are trying to deport migrants and
they put a temporary alt on that but
they they do not want all this influx of
migrants into their countries and
i mean i take a poll on americans from
americans what do you think that poll
would be stephen
it would be 90 10 no here's the bottom
line to sum it all up there's a lot of
people in afghanistan millions and
millions and millions who don't like the
taliban and rightly so that doesn't
necessarily mean that all those millions
of people are jacksonian democrats who
are pro-american and who will embrace
our way of life the most logical thing
to do for people who don't want to live
in afghanistan anymore is to find them a
home in another country in southeast
asia or the broader middle east say safe
home uh and and we do thank the people
who helped us but
hundreds of thousands of people that
ultimately is what i think the left
wants stephen thank you hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else